c'est vrai que la justice financière a
changé c'est tout à fait juste et que
désormais les juges financiers je pense
que c'est une expérience d'année
d'années de justice financière emploie
les moyens de la justice ordinaire
y compris en matière économique et
financière et on n'était pas habitués à
ça et peut-être qu'on ne le supporte pas
pour certains c'est vrai que les là la
justice ordinaire la justice pénale
ordinaire emploi comme moyens et c'est
tout à fait licite des écoutes
téléphoniques des gardes à vue des
interrogatoires successives des
confrontations etc etc on n'était pas
habitués à ça et c'est vrai que
maintenant mes juges financiers se sont
réfléchies et considérés eux y avait pas
de raison de séparer les méthodes
judiciaire prévue par le code de
procédure pénale entre la criminalité
organisée par exemple et les affaires
économiques et financières
on peut considérer que c'est de la
délinquance en col blanc et que ces
messieurs puisque je crois que la
plupart sont des messieurs devrait être
traitée différemment du citoyen lambda
mais c'est vrai que ça n'est plus la
pratique actuelle je pense que les
jeunes juges financiers maintenant vous
savez et ont eu des icônes à il ya eu
renault vendre bac qui est désormais en
retraite il y a eu et val joly et un
certain nombre de magistrats c'est vrai
qu'ils ont passé le concours de la
magistrature avait en tête ces
magistrats là qui sont des figures
judiciaire et pour eux en tout cas la
délinquance financière et la délinquance
environnementale j'ai présidé pendant
quelques années là une chambre de paris
qui était spécialisée en délinquance
environnementale
on voit désormais que le parquet pour
suite très systématiquement toutes les
infractions à l'environnement ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant voyez les
choses changent beaucoup il ya une
demande
je pense qu'il ya une demande citoyenne
sociale que ces infractions soit
traité comme les autres
[Musique]